foreign
then for your Saturday evening press
preview it's our first look at what is
on tomorrow's front pages and tonight
we'll be checking out those headlines
with former number 10 speechwriter ASA
Bennett and journalist and broadcaster
Jenny cleeman great to see you both
we'll chat in a moment we're going to
have a look at those front pages for you
one story pretty much dominating we'll
start with the Sunday Express leading on
football shows being forced off air at
the BBC after high profile presenters
and pundits as well all walked out in
solidarity with Gary lineker the
Sunday's holograph leads on the BBC's
director General refusing to resign over
the rail
same story on the front of the Sunday
Times
and the Observer their headline linika
Rao threatens to topple BBC Chief sand
hit Asylum plan
while the male reports on the reaction
from prime minister Rishi sunak who said
it's a matter for the BBC not the
government
is tomorrow's star leading with off off
off
lineker I'll never be silenced the
mirror leads with Gary's messages to the
bib
and don't forget you can scan the QR
code that you can see on screen that
right now and join the program check out
those front pages while you watch us
discussing them and I am joined tonight
by Acer Bennett and Jenny cleeman lovely
to see you both this Saturday evening
and it's interesting isn't it one story
uh dominating every single front page it
does happen from time to time but pretty
rare just shows doesn't it um how the
last 24 hours this story has exploded um
Jenny looking at the Sunday Express BBC
Sports blackout still on air match of
the day but looking incredibly different
tonight
yes match of the day uh with no
commentary no punditry no presenters
perhaps some people are switching over
from match of the day to watch us where
we're going to have some real commentary
on this tonight let's hope so
one of many programs that that isn't
running as expected today Football Focus
final score pulled from the schedules
five lives football coverage
significantly reduced today I mean what
a crisis this is for the BBC if BBC
bosses hoped that they would be drawing
a line under this Ferrari yesterday when
they said Clinica wouldn't be presented
they they showed terrible misjudgment
um this is what some have been calling
the I am Sportacus moment this invisible
picket line that Sports presenters uh
would be fools to cross because there is
such a a momentum behind supporting Gary
lineker certainly among Sports
presenters spare a thought for the poor
BBC staff many of whom are freelance
behind the scenes who will be taking a
hit for this who won't be paid or maybe
they will be paid but who who won't be
able to work today I read that they
can't pull match of the day because uh
the BBC is contractually obliged to show
highlights from the Premier League so
instead it's this very straight range a
silent program without commentary it's
this is humiliating and embarrassing for
the BBC and everybody is going to notice
because you either follow what maybe
some people follow all of it but the
people who follow football will notice
the people who follow politics will
notice the people who follow the news
will notice so this is such a disaster
so misjudged so badly handled by the BBC
and uh you know this all seemed to be
blowing over I thought by Friday morning
why did the BBC inflict this wound upon
themselves so late uh the BBC has
undermined its own credibility uh in
their mishandling of all of this they
totally didn't anticipate that this was
going to happen yeah Ace front of the
Daily Star just puts it into sharp Focus
off off off uh Football Focus final
score Radio 5 footy player interviews uh
Mark Chapman Kelly Summers Gary lineker
Jason Muhammad
um this is a a crisis Now isn't it for
the BBC which they could have avoided
like Jenny's saying
absolutely for BBC it's very much a
self-inflicted crisis it's one where
they thought they could you know blow
the whistle and garden like her send him
off for you know keep him on the subs
bench while they just let things cool
down perhaps but in essence everyone
else is then rushed off to join him you
know it is that sort of strike action
practically
um and it what's particularly the
bizarre with it is for days the and they
did longer than this the BBC has
maintained that you know what matters is
if it's you news presenters being
impartial and that Sports and others are
more than entitled to have their own
opinions you know off air
um yeah that's why for example Lord
sugar with his business program he's
able to tweet and endorse candidates
election time while still presenting a
BBC show
um that's why you know Chris Packham an
environmentalist is able to still you
know tweet on all sorts of campaign
interests you know Thurgood Sharkey and
they're still involved in BBC shows
um but at this point I suspect the dam
broke because lineaker is so box office
he is the BBC's best paid presenter that
they felt they need to make an example
of him but in that process they've
opened up a real can of worms now
because the BBC gets to do one that
loves doing best which is debating
itself and realizing that it has to set
its policy and gear now of what actually
means for impartiality for everyone not
just the new staff the the issue
generally is you know if if you look at
it from a a very basic level the BBC has
impartiality rules if you read the rules
Gary lineker has broken them that's
black and white isn't it the question is
I guess are the impartiality rules good
enough or do they need rewriting and I
suppose that's one way that the BBC
could Step Back From This Is It
well I think the impartiality rules
aren't very black and white and they're
applied very inconsistently a lot of
people were sharing on social media
today responses they'd had from the
complaints unit when they'd complained
for example about Andrew Neal uh or
about Chris Packham political statements
they've made on Twitter and the
responses they got from the BBC were
these people are freelance they are
tweeting in in a personal capacity and
the the BBC impartiality rules don't
apply in that respect and in fact they
said as much uh when Gary lineker the
last time there was a fury about Gary
lineker expressing his opinions I
understand that the BBC impartiality
rules have been tightened since then and
there is some relevance given to how big
a star you are but I think a lot of this
comes down to the fact that he is the
best paid person at the BBC and so
there's a particular focus on him but
he's a Sports pundit you know the idea
that he's influencing public opinion uh
on on politics you know if he was that
influential
City we'd all be supporting Leicester
city do you know what I mean he shows he
shares his opinions on that as well yes
he has a lot of followers and yes he's
paid a lot of money but I think the
problem is that these these rules are
not very clear and if they are clear
they're not being applied in a
consistent way
um so nobody knows where they stand okay
front of the daily uh front of the mail
on Sunday Ace uh prime minister hits
back in ninica storm
um a bit like Tim Davey actually the
director General um hasn't said anything
for the last uh um uh 24 hours or so but
they did both break their silence um a
bit earlier on today what did you make
of what the Prime Minister had to say
well I think the Prime Minister was
trying to take it back to First
principles
um and why we must remember this whole
argument began is because Gary lineker
waded in with his opinion on uh what the
government is doing to stop the boats
coming over the English Channel to deal
with illegal migration and so the Prime
Minister and this team are then trying
to bring it back to you know the big
wider relative problem saying that you
know yes they want Garrett in the BBC's
to sort themselves out they'll leave
them to it they want nothing but the
best but we have to remember you know
the scale of the problem we Face here
um and that this is why the government's
determined to you know do what matters
and yeah as is one of our big priorities
I think from a com's angle essentially
there's that every day the government's
talking about his priorities like this
they're going to stop in the boats it
then would be with winning the air War
every day they're talking about
something else like Gary denica or BBC
impartiality rules or whether actually
the BC director General should resign
they are not cutting through so that's
why he wants to try and bring it back to
what he wants to talk about and just
staying with you briefly um as you said
do you think the gov government as it's
been criticized that does put undue
pressure on the BBC
um so I think obviously the premise has
been very careful not to criticize BBC
or Gary lineker on this they are staying
out of The Fray I think by contrast
there are Tory MPS who've been writing
to the BBC and piling all the pressure
and I think that may be also what
um forced the forced Aunty to try and
you know throw a bone to the critics
okay um and the front of the Sunday
Telegraph uh Jenny I won't quit says BBC
bosses he uh hints at a climb down let's
just have a look at what he said I mean
he's obviously hoping for a resolution
he says the right outcome would be uh to
get him back on air
um both seem to be digging in though how
do you think this is going to be
resolved
it was one of these extraordinary things
where the BBC interviews the BBC and
says oh it's an exclusive we've got an
exclusive interview with the director
you see yeah
um I think they need to reinstate Gary
lineker immediately they need to clarify
the guidelines they need to stop being
cowed by the Tories and the Daily Mail
because this was a victory for the Daily
Mail
um and they need to address the issues
with the Tory chairman Richard Sharp who
is himself in Brooklyn in a a
complicated investigation uh he chairs
the board that is deciding on the Gary
lineker situation and he himself is
under investigation for failing to
disclose that he was acting as a
go-between when Boris Johnson was in
financial difficulty and looking for a
loan you have to remember that Tim Davey
uh when he took the director General job
in 2020 he said impartiality was his
number one priority so you would think
that he would have some clarity on all
of this he's going to be under a lot of
pressure over the next few days in the
comments that he made in this interview
today he was really it says in in the
piece extending an olive branch uh to
Gary lineker you know know you could say
that he was flattering him greatly
saying that he was a greatest sports
broadcaster in the world he clearly
wants this situation to be diffused but
you know it's got a momentum now that I
think the BBC never really considered
and you know we should be talking about
the government's uh immigration policy
illegal immigration policy which the
government itself accepts is probably
breaking international law and instead
we're talking about the BBC it is quite
an absurd situation to be in and this is
all because BBC management has handled
it so badly yeah we've just got 30
seconds to uh to show one more paper
front of the mirror linnica I'll never
be silenced they've got the extra detail
that he's going to be eating cottage pie
this evening instead of watching uh
match of the day at cottage pie not
Humble Pie Acer
um and and same question to you really
how do you think this is all going to
end
well the basically BBC is going to have
to have a medium mouth apology
um and Gary He's not going to be
deleting his Twitter account anytime
soon that's what we'll know so he's
going to stay on the BBC you reckon
very much so yeah um you know or but
yeah he can always fall back in other
things like his sideline as a crisp
salesman or his uh work as a podcasting
mogul